- This is a disgusting video.
(laughing)
(magical music)
(disc scratching)
Bring out the Disney DILFs.
- I'm disgusted myself.
James, Tiana's dad.
- From Princess and The Frog.
- He's pretty.
- He's very cute.
- He's pretty attractive.
- Oh, he's a hottie.
- Hell yeah.
- He's a certified hottie.
- Yes.
- Yeah, he's good.
- Sorry, he's emotionally stable,
he knows how to work hard.
(fast forwarding voices)
His beignets.
- He's got style, he's got grace.
- He would never cheat on you.
- Mmm, yeah.
Got a nice like deep, husky voice.
- Mm-hmm.
- Baby, James.
- Whisper in my ear, late at night.
- Oh.
- That is a man right there,
with that southern droll?
(sighing)
- Elsa's dad,
who I've truly never really
thought about that much.
- Oh?
- Mmm, no.
(laughing)
(grunting)
- He's a mustache.
- And the sideburns.
- No.
- Not a dilf.
- He looks a little creepy.
- He looks like he wears
Reeboks Final Fours.
- He's like, look kid,
I'm (mumbling) in box.
- The sideburns gotta go.
- Tiny mustache gotta go.
Elsa's dad in general.
- [Both] Gotta go.
- Okay, Mufasa, Mufasa,
Mufasa, age old question,
like why are The Lion King
characters a little bit hot?
- A little bit, a lot of it.
- Mufasa is hot.
He's got nice ass hair.
- Look at that mane.
- If I was a lioness?
- You would be all up in that.
- He's that like dad that
picks the kid up at school
and everyone's like oh.
- He's a top notch dilf.
- I need a Mufasa in my life.
- You could have my Simba anytime.
- This one I'm not even
gonna like weigh into,
like I'm mad, I'm giving
it a zero already.
- Marlin
- Marlin, from Finding Nemo.
- Fucking Marlin.
- Oh, Marlin! (laughing)
- I'm going home.
- This has like a lot
of emotional baggage,
which I don't wanna take on.
- Look at his face though.
(laughing)
- First of all, it's a fucking clown fish.
- As a fish, he's not even that hot.
I feel like I've seen hotter fish.
When Nemo gets put in the tank
and there's that guy who's like
really dark and mysterious,
that guy is a fish I'd fuck. (laughing)
- Get Marlin off my screen.
- Oh, Tarzan's dad.
- Tarzan's dad, okay.
- I already know he's gonna be hot.
- This whole family is beautiful.
- Hot.
- Tarzan's like that family
where like the grandpa,
the dad, Tarzan, his son,
they're all fine.
- The long hair, the
mustache, the mutton chops,
it's like 18th century
heat, sexy, swag.
- He lives in the jungle, that's hot.
- He'd be passionate as hell.
- Tarzan's dad 10 out of 10.
- I don't know if we'll
find a dilf hotter than him.
- Dilf meter?
(bell dinging)
- Riley's dad from Inside Out,
which we all know he's a certified hottie.
- Oh no!
Why did you show me his booty?
- Oh, that butt though, he's gotta dong.
- That ass.
You mean you didn't pause this scene
when you were watching the movie.
- He just looks like he's
like, I'm cool, right?
Like, it's lit.
- You're gonna say dad,
this is what a dad is.
- I feel just like make
really bad dad jokes.
- I feel like he might be a little boring.
- Yeah.
- But still hot.
- He looks like he probably,
you know, works at Charles Schwab.
I'd give this like a seven.
(laughing)
- Thank you for blessing us Pixar.
- I just hope we're not
the only ones out there
who are like looking at these dilfs
like what they got goin' on over there.
I hope that the whole world can join us
in this discovery.
- I can confirm
after doing this video,
Buzzfeed has run out of ideas.
(laughing)
- [Girl] Thank you everyone.
Thanks for tuning in.
(laughing)
(electronic whooshing)
(light orchestral music)